- It’s not very many people really know,
but the Great Lakes has
thousands of shipwrecks.
In Wisconsin for sure, we know we have 750
historic shipwreck losses.
(upbeat music)
My name is Caitlin Zant, and
I'm a maritime archaeologist
with the Wisconsin Historical Society.
I would say the main goal of what we do
in maritime archaeology is to preserve
our maritime history
and also the history of
the United States in general.
The ships are quite sturdy,
but they've also been underwater for
up to a hundred, 150 years.
Our shipwrecks don't disappear over time
like they do in the oceans.
The fresh water that's very cold
actually does a really good job at
preserving these shipwrecks.
One of the really great
things about Lake Michigan
that makes it really unique
is the fact that you do
have fresh, clear water.
You can see many times,
especially on deep wrecks
a hundred to 150 feet.
When you are down there
looking at a shipwreck
you start to think of all the
sailors that sailed on it,
or if it was a passenger ship,
the passengers that happened to be on it.
You can still find pieces of clothing
in certain areas, buttons, shoes,
and so that really gives insight
to the lives of these sailors.
There's definitely a little
bit of a thrill of discovery.
When we go down on a ship,
even on a ship that we know,
we think we know what it is.
There's still always that little
sense of excitement that
you're gonna find something
that no one else has seen before.
(water gurgling)
(playful ambient music)
(water gurgles)